>> Tucker: THIS IS A FOX NEWS
ALERT AND WE DON’T SAY THAT
LIGHTLY.
THE TWO OF THE DEMOCRATIC
NATIONAL CONVENTION BEGINS
TONIGHT FEATURING BILL CLINTON
AND ALEXANDRIA OKAY TEST.
SANDY.
WILL BE MONITORING IT.
WE’VE LOOKED AT THE DEMOCRATS
PLATFORM AND FOUND NOTHING
INTERESTING.
THEY’LL THINK IT’S SAFE FOR
AFRICAN-AMERICANS TO GO OUTSIDE.
AS A PLATFORM SAYS "IT’S
UNCOMFORTABLE THAT MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE IN OUR COUNTRY HAVE GOOD
REASON TO FEAR THEY MAY LOSE
THEIR LIVES IN A ROUTINE TRAFFIC
STOP OR STANDING ON A STREET
CORNER OR WHILE PLAYING WITH A
TOY IN A PUBLIC PARK."
IT’S SCARY.
IS IT TRUE?
MICHELLE OBAMA ECHOED THIS
SENTIMENT RECENTLY.
IN FACT LAST NIGHT.
BUT AGAIN ISN’T ROOTED IN
REALITY?
JASON WHITLOCK HAS BEEN WATCHING
CAREFULLY.
HE WRITES FOR AND IS PART OWNER
OF OUTTAKE.COM.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF IT?
YOU HEAR IT A LOT.
>> I THINK THAT FEAR ISN’T
MECHANISM, A TOOL FOR CONTROL.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA ARE USING FEAR
TO CONTROL PEOPLE AND TO CONTROL
AFRICAN-AMERICANS IN PARTICULAR.
YOU CANNOT FUNCTION PROPERLY IF
YOU LIVE IN IRRATIONAL FEAR.
AGAIN, FOR THOSE OF US THAT HAVE
RELIGIOUS FAITH, WE UNDERSTAND
THAT FEAR IS THE FRIEND OF EVIL
AND THE REASON YOU EMBRACE FAITH
IS SO THAT YOU CAN OPERATE
WITHOUT FEAR AND YOU CAN REACH
YOUR HIGHEST POTENTIAL.
THIS IS JUST AN IRRATIONAL FEAR.
WHEN THEY PUT THAT INTO THE
PLATFORM, WHEN MICHELLE OBAMA
ECHOES THOSE THOUGHTS, I AM JUST
LIKE, WHAT BLACK COMMUNITIES
HAVE ACTUALLY LIVED IN?
BECAUSE THAT IS NOT THE FEAR
THAT IS PERVASIVE THROUGHOUT
BLACK COMMUNITIES.
FEAR OF BEING STOPPED BY THE
POLICE AND KILLED.
THE STATS, THE FACTS, THE
EVIDENCE DON’T BACK UP THIS
FEAR.
SO WHY IS SOMEONE TRYING TO
INSTILL THAT FEAR IN US OF THE
POLICE?
IT’S LIKE A SELF-FULFILLING
PROPHECY.
IF YOU ENGAGE WITH THE POLICE
FILLED WITH FEAR, YOU’RE MORE
LIKELY TO MAKE REALLY BAD
DECISIONS THAT THEN PROVOKE THEM
TO TAKE ACTION.
IT’S IRRESPONSIBLE WHAT THEY’RE
DOING WHAT THEY’RE SAYING.
>> Tucker: I NEVER THOUGHT OF
THAT PART OF IT BUT YOU’RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT AND YOU’RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THAT FEAR MAKES
EVERY SINGLE HUMAN BEING
IRRATIONAL.
ME, YOU, EVERYBODY.
SO I WONDER WHAT THE LONG-TERM
CONSEQUENCES OF THIS HOUR, APART
FROM THE ONE YOU JUST MENTIONED.
WHAT KIND OF SCAR DOES THIS
LEAVE ON THE COUNTRY IF YOU KEEP
SAYING STUFF LIKE THIS?
>> THE NUMBER ONE THING YOU CAN
DO TO PREVENT SOMEONE FROM
REACHING THEIR POTENTIAL IS
CONVINCE THEM THAT THEY CAN’T.
AND TO CONVINCE HIM THAT THE
WHOLE COUNTRY IS AGAINST THEM.
THEREFORE WHY EVEN TRY?
GIVE SOMEONE AN EXCUSE NOT TO BE
SUCCESSFUL.
GIVE SOMEONE AN EXCUSE TO BEHAVE
IMPROPERLY WHEN DEALING WITH THE
POLICE.
IT’S HOW YOU ENSURE FAILURE.
I WAS BROUGHT UP MY ENTIRE LIFE
TO GO OUT AND ATTACK THE WORLD
AND ANYTHING WAS A POSSIBILITY.
THAT WAS THE HOPE THAT WAS PUT
IN ME.
I WAS BORN IN 1957.
MY PARENTS LIVED THROUGH THE
CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT.
THEIR GOAL, THEIR HOPE FOR ME
AND MY BROTHER, MY STEPBROTHER
AND STEPSISTER WAS FOR US TO GO
OUT AND CONQUER THE WORLD.
WE ARE NOW TELLING KIDS YOU
CAN’T CONQUER THE WORLD.
SO IF YOU’RE A BLACK KID
COMPETING AGAINST ASIAN KIDS,
WHITE KIDS, LATINO KIDS, AND
YOU’VE BEEN CONVINCED THE WHOLE
SYSTEM IS RIGGED AGAINST YOU,
YOU CAN’T SUCCEED, AND THE OTHER
KID YOU’RE COMPETING WITH OUR
AUTHOR, THE WORLD IS ON A
PLATTER FOR ME.
IF I GO OUT AND ATTACK AND WORK
HARD ALL BE SUCCESSFUL.
YOU HAVE LESS OF A CHANCE OF
COMPETING AGAINST YOUR PEERS IF
YOUR ATTITUDE AND MIND-SET ARE
RIGHT.
ATTITUDE CONTROLS OUTCOME.
I’M SORRY, IT’S PURE EVIL.
IT’S BORDERLINE SATANIC.
IF YOU REALLY HAVE AN
UNDERSTANDING OF RELIGIOUS
FAITH, THE PRINCIPLES TAUGHT IN
THE BIBLE, WHY JESUS DIED ON THE
CROSS FOR US.
IF GOD IS ON YOUR SIDE, HOW CAN
YOU FAIL?
IT IS SICKENING TO ME WHAT THIS
MESSAGE AND TO SEE A MAJOR
POLITICAL PARTY PUMP THIS
MESSAGE INTO THE BLACK COMMUNITY
IS REALLY DISHEARTENING FOR ME.
>> Tucker: [LAUGHS]
YOU’RE MAKING ME EMOTIONAL.